Today's guest uses history to predict
wars, elections, and the end of the
world. What's your prediction for60?
I think by60 we will have reached this
fork in the world where you do have
communities that are AI controlled.
Everyone is perfectly happy being a
microchip, perfectly happy being a slave
to the system, and you have other
communities who are trying to
>> A son of Chinese immigrants in Toronto,
he grew up poor, invisible, and obsessed
with how power actually works.
>> Who do you think is Satoshi Nakamoto?
They say that it translates into central
intelligence. And when you do game
theory analysis, you look at all
possibilities. You end up with a deep
state. You end up with a CIA. Now, a
high school history teacher in China,
he's predicted Trump winning the
election, America's invasion of
Venezuela, and recently the war between
Iran and the US. What can I do that
makes me so distinct that I might be
popular on social media? And my solution
was I'm going to make some stupid
predictions and if they aren't correct
I'm going to be a laughing stock for the
rest of my life. But if they are correct
then I might get on Taco Carson. In this
episode we'll break down the system he
uses to predict the future. Examine why
he's certain America will lose the war
in Iran and question if he is a crazy
conspiracy theorist or the only person
willing to say the truth about what's
coming next. Professor Jeang, are you a
spy?
Professor Jeang, welcome to the Jack
Neil podcast.
>> Thanks, Jack.
>> So, by 2045,
and this is where it gets interesting.
What do you think happens in 2045?
Complete chaos. I think you will
experience something akin to the Bronze
Age collapse, which is a total systems
collapse. It'll be brought on by
environmental catastrophe. So there's
something called the geomagnetic
excursion event which is like the north
and south pole start to move away from
the present locations which then weakens
the earth's magnetic field which then um
makes the earth much more susceptible to
solar flares which which are basically
EMP shock waves which would destroy the
digital economy right but the entire
world is basically digitized so imagine
a solar flare in the middle of New York
City well no one would have access to
the internet, uh, telecommunications,
uh, the car won't work, the power plants
will give out. You, if it's winter, you
will literally freeze to death. Uh,
sanitation breaks breaks down. There's
no more clean water. It'll be complete
chaos. And it it will only take one of
these events to destroy a lot of the
world because we're so congregated
inside cities.
Okay. So I think there's a real
possibility in next 20 years there will
be a major environmental catastrophe. Um
and it's possible it's a perfect storm
of catastrophes in meaning pestilence,
famine,
um drought, um um earthquakes, just a
perfect storm
and in which case you will have a
shattering of the world. So the nation
state then gives way to the city state
and these city states have to fight
amongst each other for precious
resources especially water.
Um and so it's not a very pleasant
future for humanity but this is
something that I don't think people are
really prepared for. Yes I I I
understand there will be a multipolar
world and that is in the in the midterm
but in the long term we have to worry
about diverse survival of humanity
itself. What do you think will be the
dominant nation at that time?
>> Um, I think people will be surprised by
how resilient the Germans and the
Japanese are. I think in the in the in
the midterm
North America,
uh, Moscow, Israel will be very
dominant. But over time, I think people
will be surprised by the resurgence of
the Germans and the Japanese. The
Germans are headed towards military
humiliation in Ukraine. They can't
possibly beat beat beat the Russians in
Ukraine. But it may be in the long term
good for Germany because then after
those loss, the Germans may be able to
rediscover their national identity,
their heritage and build a stronger
nation out of this collapse. The
Japanese have been the most resilient
people in human history.
Um,
I mean the things they've been able to
accomplish as a very small nation are
just incredible. So you go back to the
13th century when the Mongols invaded
Japan twice and the Japanese which was
at this time a feudal society broken up
into like different kingdoms waring
against each other. They unified as a
people to repel this invasion from at
that time the greatest empire in the
world. Then you go to the 19th century
when China was being carved up by the
western powers and it seemed as though
Japan was going to be carved up as well.
But then Japan started something called
the Maji restoration and they start to
industrialize and then in like 30 40
years they defeated Russia in a war and
that was unimaginable to people at that
time. Go back to 1945. America was
firebombing Japan, destroying all of
Japan's infrastructure industry.
Millions of people were burning to
death. America dropped two bombs, two
nuclear bombs on Japan.
After World War II, within a generation,
they became the most dominant
manufacturing power in the world.
So
if you look at East Asia, it's in a lot
of trouble, but never ever bet against
the Japanese. The way I had it was
essentially 2030 was
Russia expanding into Eastern Europe,
Asia is in crisis, and America
collapses. Historically, an empire
falls, another one rises. This is where
Israel starts to replace America as like
the global uh superpower
pack Judea and then the ultimate endgame
is a one world AI surveillance state
with the global matrix of control being
headquartered in Jerusalem. Is that what
you see happening by 2045 or is that
what they see?
>> Okay. All right. So let's differentiate
between Greater Israel project and praa.
Okay. So, Greater Israel Project is the
idea that
Israel needs to achieve the promised
land, which they believe is what Yahweh
promised to their ancestor Abraham. And
this promised land, if you look at a
map, extends from the Nile in Egypt to
the Euphrates and Iraq. It also includes
parts of of Anatolia, Turkey, as well as
parts of Saudi Arabia. And so you can
make the argument that what Israel wants
to achieve in this war is the greater
Israel project. Meaning that it wants to
extend this war as much as possible to
drag in as many players as possible
including Turkey, including Saudi Arabia
because if they're destroying this war,
then it's just easier for uh Israel to
achieve the greater Israel project. And
then they want to make Jerusalem the the
capital of this empire. and build the
third temple and and this will allow for
the Messiah to come. That's how they how
how these religious Zionists see things
unfolding. Pax Judea is different. Pax
Judea is transnational capital seeing an
opportunity in greater Israel and saying
well if you guys are going to achieve
the greater Israel project we'll come in
and finance all this and we'll help with
the building of the AI surveillance
state. So there there are not that many
Jews. So we'll we'll hire mercenaries
to be the military for this empire.
We'll also bring in millions of Indians,
Chinese, Filipinos to work as slaves in
this uh empire. Um and we will use the
an AI surveillance state to keep this
system in check.
Right? So every slave will be given a
microchip
and um well and there's unlimited oil
and energy in the Middle East. So we're
going to have all these data centers in
the Middle East. Okay. That's how they
want this world to turn out,
>> right? Okay. So, so the distinction is
you you're saying it's kind of AI um and
tech versus traditional finance, but
people have to understand that AI was a
project of people on the transnational
capital side originally.
>> Right. Right. Right. So, so um the
distinctions aren't as clear as I make
them out to be.
>> Right. Because like let's just say
you're a billionaire like Peter Theo.
You're going to play both sides, right?
You're going to see how the political
wind shift and you're going to position
yourself in a way that allows you to
maximize your benefit. You're not going
to be like, I'm only for my team. That's
not how these people are. They have
actually no loyalties. You look at
someone like Jeffrey Epstein who knew
everyone and who was on um everyone's
good graces. Like that's how they
behave. They're trying to uh in a in a
time of chaos trying to position
position themselves in a way so that
they individually benefit. they
absolutely no no loyalty to anyone.
Okay.
>> Right.
>> So the greater Israel project um is just
what the Jews want to achieve. Okay. The
the religious Jews want to achieve. But
but the uh trans capital
wants to make Israel their their new
center of operations. But it's not
limited to just finance and AI. It's
also limited to weapons manufacturing.
Right? Because if the world is going
into chaos, they're going to fight wars
against each other. So, let's make
weapons for them, right? Um it'll also
be um food production and uh because
Africa will be suffering during this
time. So what you want to do is you want
to take these um food supply basically
carbohydrates from Russia and then add
value it to it in greater Israel pasa
and then transfer to the Middle East and
to Africa as well. So the opportunities
in the Middle East are almost unlimited
because because of its resources because
of its location uh and because of the
technology that Israel has. Did you
think at one point that Pax Judea and
the Greater Israel project coming to
fruition was like pretty set in stone
and was there like a key event recently
or in the past couple years that made
you think that that's not the case
anymore,
>> right? Um, okay. So, before I actually
believe that this was going to happen
sooner or later,
but quite honestly, this war in the
Middle East has surprised me because I
did not actually imagine the Iranians to
be this
um resilient. I didn't imagine that they
would dominate the war in the way they
are. I predicted that America would lose
the war because I thought the Americans
would be incompetent that they would be
to become too arrogant. They would
extend too far into Iran and they would
get bogged down and then they would just
collapse.
>> But the Iranians are controlling the
escalation ladder very strategically.
Um they're able to control the the
narrative very well.
>> Like there are a lot of Americans who
actually rooting for the Iranians. I
mean that's incredible to think about.
Um, and so I think we should not
discount Persia. Uh, the Persians are an
extremely creative people. They um have
been around for at least 3,000 years and
they claim a legacy that is even richer
than the than the Jewish legacy. So, um,
how Iran will develop is something that
that I think will surprise people
because I always imagine that this word
would devastate Iran. But if Iran is
able to stay intact,
well, they can be a competitor to
patcha, right? Because Iran also has a
lot of resources. It's also in a very
central location and it will uh have
really really good trade relations with
both China and Russia. So it actually it
actually create a trade block in
competition with Pakudea. There'll be a
lot of overlaps. There'll be a lot of
cooperation. But uh Persia could be a
counterweight to Pax Judeica
which might also lead to the war of Gog
and Magog which is what is part of their
esqueological script.
>> In some calculations
uh they think that Gog and Magog
represent Persia and Russia. So they see
eventually a war between Israel against
alliance of Persia and Russia. Is there
anything else you wanted to add to
predictions for by 2045 that you think
are guaranteed despite how this war
plays out? I think you'll have
population collapse around the world
because what people don't appreciate is
that
um we borrow from the future to finance
today. We shouldn't have 8 billion
people around and like there are
billions who live middle class
lifestyles. If you're a middle-ass
American today, you have a more
extravagant lifestyle than the Roman
emperors did.
>> You're able to travel anywhere around
the world. Today, if you wanted to, you
could go online, book a flight to the
Maldes and be on be there like in a
couple days in a, you know, five-star
resort. And in the Malds, you could be
eating avocados from Mexico. You could
be sipping red wine from Chile. It's
incredible the world that the world that
we've created. and we made it accessible
to just an average American or
Westerner. That's incredible to think
about. But we have to remember that this
is all an illusion and we've been able
to create this because we borrowed from
the future and we've mortgaged the
future and eventually the bill is going
to come due. And so in a time of war
when supply chains are disrupted
then you're going to have a lot of
issues including famine. So um one
trend that I I think people don't
appreciate is how our values our sense
of decency enormousy will change over
time as economies become worse and
worse. We think we believe today that we
are so much superior to the past because
we've eliminated famines, we've
eliminated slavery, we've eliminated
genocide.
But who's to say that as things get
worse and worse, these things won't
return and they won't be normalized,
right? If there there's not not much
water to go around, if there's not
enough food to go around, then you're
going to have these issues, right? So,
so I think people will be at first
shocked by how rapidly the world
declines both both in terms of
population, morality, decency.
Um, and I think people will be even more
surprised by how quickly we become
desensitized,
how quickly we normalize this new world
that we are in. And you know, if you
just go back to recent history, we've
changed a lot um, in these past 10
years. 2016 was election of Donald
Trump. No one thought that was possible.
Then you had COVID happen. No one
thought that was possible. Then you had
Russia invade Ukraine. No, we didn't
think that was possible. Now America has
invaded Iran. We didn't think that was
possible. But each time we became
normalized, desensitized to the event
and it's become part of our um memory
and um we sort of um memory hold a lot
of the trauma.
You've said that Isaac Newton, who many
people just think of as a famous
scientist and physicist, actually spent
most of his life studying the Bible and
trying to calculate when the world would
end. Newton said the world would end
in60, and you've said that people with
unlimited power believe him and are
executing his plan.
What do you think will happen by60?
I think by60,
um, the world will be in complete chaos.
It'll be the new dark ages. There'll be
there'll be no central authority.
There'll be catastrophe after
catastrophe. Um there'll be floods
everywhere. There'll be earthquakes. Um
there will be um
um uh there'll be population collapse.
And
um I think that humanity will have
entered the darkest age it's experienced
for thousands of of years.
And I think at this time
what's going to happen is
that
humanity will reach a um
fork in the road.
Um and there'll be some people who are
like
we need to return to the past. We need
to return to central authority. We can
use AI to create God. And once you we
create AI, this AI god, people have no
memory that was an AI.
And um
we can use
this god to create a perfect world.
There'll be there'll be a lot of people
people like that and these are the most
powerful people, right? And people will
think well then we will we will have
ended history because once this AI god
is in place and no one knows it's AI and
thinks is this god then people will be
completely obedient. People will be
reasonable people be rational people
people will obey whatever this god tells
them to do. But then you'll have another
set of people in the minority who are
like
this is a perversion
of humanity. This is like brave new
world.
This is using drugs. It's using
technology to enslave the human
imagination, the human consciousness.
And we're not here in this world to just
be obedient slaves. We're here to take
risk. We're here to explore. We're here
to ask questions. And
we have to fight to leave a legacy of
freedom.
of imagination to our children. And so I
think that by60
um we will have reached this fork in the
world where you do have communities that
are AI um controlled. You have an AI
surveillance state where everyone is
perfectly happy being a microchip,
perfectly happy um being a slave to the
system. And you have other communities
which are uh weaker which which are the
minority um who are trying to salvage
what makes us human and trying to find a
new spiritual path for humanity
and this is will be the great defining
struggle of60
um around that that that that that area
while at the same time we have to
remember there are still wars going on
there's still a lot of environmental
catastrophe going on brought on by the
geometic uh excursion. Um there might
have been a nuclear war by this point.
Do you believe that the god everyone
worships today is AI? Have you ever
thought about how many different
software subscriptions you're using to
run your business or social media
channels? Because if you're like me,
you're probably doing email marketing on
one platform. You're running your
website on another platform, customer
support, CRM somewhere else, and you're
spending thousands of dollars a month on
all these tools, and you barely can keep
track of all of it. That's why I was so
glad our team started using Highle. It's
basically the operating system for our
entire business all in one place. But
the craziest part is their AI studio.
Anything you want to add to your
business, new website, better funnel,
automations, it builds it out instantly
simply by typing in a prompt. Now, be
honest with me. Are you currently paying
more than $97 a month to keep track of
your leads in a CRM? Send automated
emails and text messages, build landing
pages, and process payments. If you said
yes, you're probably going to want to
switch to HighLevel. So seriously, if
you want to stop paying for eight
different software subscriptions to run
your business, just go to
jacknealil.com/highle
or scan the QR code on screen. Again,
that is jackneil.com/hyle
if you want to run your entire business
with one platform.
But anyway, guys, back to the podcast.
Do you believe that the god everyone
worships today is AI?
I believe um in hermetic philosophy. I
think hermetic philosophy helps us best
understand the world. And so I'll just
go into the basic principles of of
hermetic philosophy to structure our
discussion. Okay. So the first idea or
the first law is that
mind is everything. The universe is
conscious and how it's conscious is
through vibrations. Okay. So the the uh
universe is energetic and it uh it's
vibrates and so vibrations are
information right so that's
consciousness. Second principle is as
above so below which is to say that in
like the universe is fractal in each
aspect of the universe is the entire
universe. So in ourselves is the
universe itself. Okay. So as above so
below so below as above. Okay. So uh
second idea. The third idea is the idea
of rhythm. The law of rhythm which which
is to say is that there is a pattern to
these vibrations. There's a pattern to
the movement of the universe to the
movement of the stars.
Number four is the idea of um
correspondence which is say that there
are different dimensions okay an
infinite set of the dimensions that
range from the material to the divine.
Okay. So the body, the heart, the mind,
the soul, these are all different
aspects of these are all different
dimensions. Okay, they all correspond to
each other and that's what enables our
individuality.
Then you have the law of cause and
effect where if we assume that the
universe is uh conscious, it's fractal.
Um it's interconnected, then whatever I
do impacts you in a certain way. It's
almost like the butterfly effect where
through individual action, through
individual faith, we can impact the
universe both in a positive or negative
light. But our actions do have
consequences.
Then you have the law of polarity which
just say that for every thing there's an
opposite right so think of ying and yang
think of thesis antithesis
whatever there is creates something that
is opposite okay then you have the law
of generation which is say that when
these opposites combine together you
create a new force okay so think of
thesis antithesis
symphysis okay and and that's how the
world the universe functions. It's
constantly seeking creation. It's
constantly seeking generation by
unifying opposing forces.
And so I think
that this is how the the universe works
and God is the universe itself. So the
movement of the universe is uh the
consciousness of of God. So we are
inside God but God is also inside us.
And so once we recognize this
um aspect of ourselves that we can exist
in multiple dimensions that we are both
an individual as well as part of a
greater collective then I think that
leads to certain actions in the world.
Okay.
Um what I believe is our time in this
world is short and it's precious
and we are eternal but we have to make
mo the most of our time here and the
Greeks have a word for this udemonia
which is flourishing. So every day we
should be asking ourselves not how much
money do we have, not what have I
achieved, but am I flourishing as a
person, meaning am I being my my most
creative self, am I learning, am I
growing, am I loving?
Um,
and I feel as though love is the uni
unifying force of the universe in that
when we love someone unconditionally,
we open our souls to the collective
conscious and and this is what drives
our imagination.
And then this imagination allows us to
be creative and make the world a more
creative place. Because again what
happens in our mind we're just a fractal
what happens in our mind is reflected
throughout the universe. So if we are
creative the world the universe becomes
creative it itself. And so um for me I
take this to mean that
my role in this
world is to use my imagination to
inspire others to use their imagination
and I do that through my teaching
but but that's how I conceptualize my
role given my understanding of the
universe. So it's not really about like
what is God and does he exist. It's more
about
how can we make God smile?
How can we ourselves make others smile
and bring joy to the universe? Imagine
that the entire world, the entire
universe, both past and future, it's all
watching your movement. what you do and
whatever you do today will be remembered
for all of eternity and you should live
accordingly to this principle and you
know Emanuel Klein calls this the
categorical imperative
how do you know what is good what is
just what is moral
if you are proud that everyone in the
universe who's ever lived and whoever
will ever live watches what you do and
smiles at you I think that's a really
fascinating philosophy and a great
takeaway. Um,
if you don't mind, I do have
a few questions
that I think now that we've covered a
timeline and kind of your view uh on all
of it and your takeaway, there are some
takeaways that I have that I found
particularly interesting from reviewing
so many of your lectures the past few
weeks. Uh, if you wanted to control
society, would you have them believe in
one god, many gods, or no god?
Okay. So, I think
that
um
we've had different societies
where we've tried either no god, many
gods, or just one god.
And I think you we you get different
societies.
So the Greeks were polytheistic at the
same time they were the most creative
people ever. I mean what they were able
to accomplish about 100 100 years is
just mindboggling because they basically
created the foundations for modern
western civilization.
Um, and their concept of polytheism
is that there are different gods
competing against each other and we're
just pawns
in this great game. And so that made
them much more thoughtful about the
reality
um of the universe like why are we here?
What what is our purpose? and their deep
introspection is what leads to their
tremendous creative output. Um so that's
the aspect of polytheism that I think is
very encouraging in that you're always
forced to ask the hard questions.
Um one god is a recent phenomenon and
it's led us to be the most energetic
people in the world. Right? So, think
about our accomplishments where we're
able to build skyscrapers, we're able to
build high-speed rails, we're able to
build airplanes, but no one ever asked
the question, why are we doing this,
right? Like, what's the point of this?
And quite honestly, if you just look at
human health index, people's happiness,
people's health, um their cancer rates,
it's it's pretty abysmal. I mean, so so
yeah. So having one god monotheism
compels us into action a sort of like
frenetic anxious action but it's also
led to tremendous human suffering. No
god is just complete and utter chaos. Um
it could lead to tremendous
individuality.
But the problem with no God is we become
God and we we feel as though we can
impose our will on others as well. And
that's the issue in China where where I
live where we never really had a god but
we had an emperor. So but the idea that
one person can become god um has led to
a very cruel and unjust world. Um, so I
would say there are strengths and
weaknesses to all systems. Um, but I
would say that it is part of the human
condition that we constantly shift
and challenge our pre-existing
conceptions of God. And that's what
allows for a lot of progress. Why did
they actually kill Jesus?
Okay. Well, first of all, we don't
really know they killed Jesus because if
you look at the Islamic tradition, there
is Jesus. Jesus is the penultimate
prophet. Muhammad is the ultimate
prophet. Um, and if you look at the
Quran, uh, if you look at the Islamic
tradition, Jesus never died. He was
never crucified. He just died peacefully
and he went up to heaven. Because the
idea is that if you're a messenger of
God, it doesn't really matter if you die
or not. what matters is are you able to
deliver the message properly and Jesus
was able to to do that. So Jesus is
revered in the Islamic tradition and um
there are different sects of
Christianity for example the Gnostics
who don't really care and don't really
even talk about his death because for
them death is rebirth death is release.
This planet that we're on is hell on
earth. We're here to enlighten others,
but once we finish our job, then we
return home to wherever we came from.
And so death is just release. It's
rebirth. It doesn't really matter if if
you die. Um, so there are people who
don't believe that Jesus died and there
are people who believe it didn't really
matter how he he died. Um but obviously
the story of the crucificiction
is something that compels people and
which drives people into this tremendous
emotional angst. You you have a lot of
war started over uh over this this this
issue. Um right. So,
um, my understanding is that if you look
at the historical evidence,
Jesus was probably crucified by the
Romans. Because why would you make this
up? Um, and he was probably crucified
because he was a threat to the status
quo, meaning that he pissed off both the
Roman authorities as well as the Jewish
authorities. And I think that he was
pissing everyone off because he was he
was providing some truth that spoke to
people intuitively but which went
against the natural order. And
>> what was that truth? I personally
believe that he was a religious genius
who had an intimate connection with the
vine and who believed
something along the lines of Nazism
hermetic philosophy and we and the
evidence for that is the gospel of
Thomas which is probably the earliest
um record of his sayings
And it and people believe some people
believe not everyone but some people
believe it actually precedes the gospel
of Mark which was about 70. Um and if
you just read the Gospel of Thomas I
think it actually aligns pretty closely
with what we know to be authentic
sayings from the other gospels including
Mark and Matthew. Um and if you read the
Gospel of Thomas it's clearly a Gnostic
worldview. Uh it's clearly believed that
we're all divine sparks and we're here
to experience the world for what it is
to sort of suffer into pain in order to
seek enlightenment. But we have to
remember our true aspects if we are tr
to truly seek knowledge and
enlightenment otherwise we become slaves
to the system. Otherwise we're too
focused on material acquisitions
otherwise we're too focused on making
money. Um and this was a direct threat
to the system because
um this would overturn the status quo,
right? The Roman society is a very
strict hierarchy. And to say that uh the
person with all the money has no
authority over me. Uh the person with
all the power has no has no authority
over me because I'm a divine soul. Uh
that could be very upsetting. So we also
know that Jesus spent a lot of time with
slaves. and the oppressed. Well, this is
a problem because a slave is considered
economic property. So, if you tell a
slave, hey man, you're a divine soul.
You shouldn't be a slave and the slaves
either decides to quite quit or runs
away, that's economic damage. And at
that time in history, if you were to
insult someone, uh, you know, you might
get hit at, but if you actually steal
from someone, they killed you, right?
Because remember remember the um
crucifificiction there were three people
who were crucified Jesus and two thieves
right so I think that Jesus with his
message was liberating slaves
psychologically and emotionally and
giving tremendous comfort to to to them
but this made them less productive
in which case you know you're causing
economic damage you know you're
destroying property
so he was considered basically a rebel
you said Paul was a spy that used Jesus
as a political symbol.
Do you think the CIA uses mind control
to create terrorists?
Um, look, I think if you just look at
the history of the Middle East, a lot of
these Islamic extremists were creation
of empire, right? So let's go back to
1950s
and the spreading of um Wahhabiism
throughout Saudi Arabia and throughout
the Islamic world
u which then became of course al Qaeda.
Well if you go back to the 1950s
this was heavily encouraged by the
Americans and the British for three
reasons. Okay. The first is that
the so America was at war with the
Soviet Union in the cold war, right? And
you couldn't fight the Soviet Union in a
battlefield because that would lead to a
nuclear war. So what you had to do is
sabotage them for move in. And there was
a sizable
Muslim minority in the Soviet Union
about I think about like maybe 20 to
30%. That's a lot of people all conceded
in the south of the Soviet Union, which
has always been problematic for the
Soviet Union, right? There there were
that many Muslims in America. So why
wouldn't you encourage fanatical violent
extremism? Right? That's number one.
That so that that works to the benefit
of the Americans and the British. Second
is that at this time in the Middle East
um the Middle East had tremendous oil,
right? And there were certain movements
in the Middle East that were that would
counter the power of the Anglo-American
Empire. This included nationalism. This
included pen arabivism and included
socialism. So you go to um Iran in 1950s
where they democratically elected a
leader who wanted to nationalize
the oil industry u rather than just give
it for free to the British, right? Um
and so
nationalism and socialism were it were
problems for the Americans and the
British. So what do you do? you promote
um Islamic extremism as a counter to
nationalism and socialism,
right? Um and uh the third thing is that
Islamic extremism destabilizes the
Middle East. We've seen this play out
over and over again. And so how does
this instability
help America and Britain? Because it
stabilizes Israel, right? So if you go
to if you go look at ISIS, it's really
funny how ISIS never attacked Israel.
You would think that these Islamic
extremists would hate Jews the most, but
for whatever reason, they've never
attacked Israel. In fact, we have quite
a few instances where the American
military arrested um an Islamic
extremist and they discovered, oh, we
have to let him go because he's a Mossad
agent.
So, there are lots if you actually just
go to the Middle East and you ask
around, they'll tell you this. They'll
tell you, well, you know, ISIS was
probably a CIA creation. um the ala
al-Qaeda or some bin Ladden were all
financed by the CIA because remember
they went from Saudi Arabia to
Afghanistan to become Mujahedin to fight
the Soviets and so the CIA finance all
this. Who do you think is Satoshi
Nakamoto?
>> Well, I mean they say that it translates
into central intelligence
and um the story makes no sense, right?
Because why would you spend years,
possibly decades in your basement
creating a new technology, the
blockchain technology and then just give
it for free to the world and
right that makes no sense.
>> It does sound a little ridiculous.
>> It sounds kind of ridiculous, right? So
then you have to ask yourself three
questions. First of all is who would
have the technology and the expertise to
create something like the blockchain.
Second of all, you have to ask who would
benefit from this blockchain creation.
The third question you want to ask is
why would they keep it secret? Okay. And
when you do game theory analysis, you
look at all possibilities,
you end up with a deep state, the
American deep state. You end up with a
CIA. Okay? So the first question, who
would have the expertise and the
technology to create the blockchain?
Probably the same people who created the
internet, probably the same people who
created GPS,
DARPA,
NSA,
CIA, probably these guys, right? If they
got the internet, uh blockchain, it's
it's just more of an enclosed model of
the internet, right? where where where
the internet is open but the blockchain
is actually closed up to certain members
but everything is transparent within the
blockchain right so um that's the first
question second question is who would
benefit from blockchain well the CIA
because of two things one is
surveillance where they're able to
monitor everything right it's it's
almost like a Trojan horse if you were
to use blockchain second is like the CIA
it does a lot of black ops it it is a
within a within a government, right? It
is basically outside of all um political
control, but it needs a mechanism to
finance it operations. It basically
needs a mining operation and block
blockchain is is a great mechanism to
finance a lot of a lot of of of its
operations, especially drug trafficking.
Okay. Third question is why would they
keep it secret? And the answer is only
if people believe
that this was transparent, open
and uh um beyond authority, beyond
political control, what does it have
value? Right? So the moment people
people recognize that this is a CIA
operation, people won't put their money
into blockchain. People won't put their
money into Bitcoin. They'll they'll be
like I mean uh why would I do that? You
have to ask yourself this question.
Where are the blockchain servers
located?
Right? Because I imagine if you're able
to control the hardware, you can also
control the software. I don't care what
they tell tell me about open source and
all that. I want to know where the
databases are, where the servers are
physically.
It's interesting too that it's it's
designed like a religion.
>> Yeah.
>> H
>> I'll I'll I'll tell something else.
Okay.
Mark Zuckerberg.
>> That's what I was going to ask about.
Yeah.
>> So Mark Zuckerberg um had his conflict
with uh the Ven Veno Voss the Winkle
>> Winkle Voss twins. Yeah.
>> The Winkle Voss twins. Okay. And so the
finger lost twins sued Mark Zuckerberg
claiming that Zuckerberg stole the idea
for Facebook from them. Okay. And this
went to court and there there was a
settlement. I I forget the amount. Okay.
But then the Voss twins took a sizable
portion of the settlement and put it all
in Bitcoin.
Like we're talking about millions of
dollars into Bitcoin when it was like
just a novelty. Why would people do
that? They're the largest individual
owners today. I believe I
>> I don't know that. But I I I'm I'm just
saying like back then, you know, when
this was a novelty, when this was a
niche thing, and these are not
technologists, right?
How why would they put millions and
millions of dollars into this thing?
That's really strange. Hey, really
quick. Do you have a 401k, a Roth IRA,
or happen to have a lot of money in
crypto? Because you're definitely going
to want to hear about this. See, the
biggest supporters of this podcast right
now are the guys over at iTrust Capital.
And when they first reached out to me
and explained what they did, it
literally sounded like a cheat code.
See, with their platform, you can
convert your existing 401k or Roth IRA
into one that lets you buy Bitcoin,
Ethereum, and over 80 cryptocurrencies
while maintaining the same tax-saving
benefits. Now, of course, you can start
a new IRA with them if you're bullish on
Bitcoin and want to save on taxes if you
ever decide to cash out. But if you're
someone who already has a lot of crypto
and you're worried about it getting
hacked or stolen, iTrust also offers a
PCA account, which is institutionalgrade
level custody, meaning your assets are
fully insured, ultra secure, and never
sitting on any risky exchanges. So, if
you guys want to get access, just go to
jacknil.com/itrust
or scan the QR code on screen. Again,
that is jackneil.comitrust
or hit the first link in the description
for an easy $100 bonus. But anyway, back
to the podcast.
You've said figures like Zuckerberg,
Elon Musk, and Bill Gates are not
geniuses, but front people.
Sam Alman didn't invent Chat GBT or
LLM's. Steve Jobs didn't invent the
iPhone. Do you think the government
invented social media and AI?
>> Um, so if you go back to 1970s,
the government had a huge credibility
problem and the Pentagon had put all
this money into the internet as a
surveillance tool, right? They wanted to
promote the internet and computers as a
way to uh control people.
But the problem is Americans had this
experience the Vietnam war
and there were the um church committee
hearings and so Americans knew the CIA
was this evil organization. So there was
actually no trust in government. There
was there was also the Watergate
hearings before that the assassinations
of like Martin Luther King, JFK, RFK.
Okay. So the government had absolutely
no trust in government. So you needed a
strategy of how to make people believe
computers were safe and cute and
innocuous.
And the strategy they came up with is
let's just open source this to nerds,
right? So if you're able to
sell computers to the public, you go
make the billions of dollars, right? So
Steve Jobs partnered with Steve
Wasniaak. Okay. And at that time, people
don't know this, but Steve Wnjak was an
employee of Huard Packard, which is a
defense contractor. Okay? And so
whatever he created actually belong as
an IP to HP, right? So, Steve Wing
creates this open-source computer
and then he goes to his uh superiors at
HB and says, "Look, I'm working for you
guys. You guys are are giving me the
paycheck.
Listen, this computer, I'm happy to give
it to you guys for to give it to you
guys." And they told him, "No, we don't
want it. No, go sell yourself. It's
yours."
And that's kind of strange.
and then he becomes a billionaire along
with with Bill Gates.
>> So HP gave Steve Wnjak the ability to
sell Mac for free. Okay. So Steve Wnak
was an employee of HP and he was trained
by HP meaning his engineering skills
came from that environment and he had
access to all of HP's technology and
that's how he was able to to construct a
personal computer from scratch, right?
because of the expertise provided to him
from his employer. So technically
it should belong to HP,
>> right?
>> But they came to agreement where HP
would not claim any IP over
uh this computer. Okay?
>> So think of a university if you're
Stanford, right? Stanford owns owns some
some some parts of Google because you
know Larry Page and and and and Sergey
Brim like develop Google at Stanford,
right? Because you you have you have you
have access to all of Stanford's um
technology and expertise.
But when Steve Wnak designed the um
Apple computer,
HB said, "No, no, no. We don't want
anything. We don't want to be involved
in this. Right.
And you ask, you have to ask yourself,
why would they do that?
I think there's about 3,000
uh like individual billionaires publicly
documented by Forbes. Like did we like a
100 years ago, was that a thing where
there were all these individual
billionaires that had these come from
nothing stories where they invented this
great product and sold it or was that
only a necessity after Vietnam?
>> Um, I think this is a recent phenomena.
If you go back to the guilded age, um
these billionaires like John D
Rockerfeller
and um Andrew Carnegie, what people
don't recognize is that like when they
died, if you actually look at their net
worth, how much they bestow onto
uh their children and grandchildren, it
was only a fraction of their total net
worth. So where did all that other money
go? Right? Um, and they were actually
spending a lot of their money on
charity. So, Andrew Andrew Carnegie,
Rockefeller were known for that. And
what people don't recognize is that they
had a problem which is
everyone assumed in America that these
were self-made billionaires. This is
American dream, right? They they they
were the paragonss of the American
dream. You come to America, you have
nothing, but then suddenly overnight by
working hard, uh, you're a billionaire
or a trillionaire. Okay? And what they
don't recognize is that these were just
agents, representatives of the city of
London. So, they need they need to
disguise the fact that they didn't
actually have that much money, right?
And the way the way they disguise that
is by donating the money to charity and
saying, "Oh, well, you know, I gave it
all away before I died.
Right.
I'll ask you,
do you think science is the most
woripped religion on earth?
This is a thought I had watching your
videos is what happens when an entire
group of people worships one religion is
it never feels like a religion. It feels
like the truth.
Look, let's look at CO, okay? So, CO,
you had this virus going around. It was
mutating very very fast.
And
um then they in like I think less than a
year, right? Eight, nine months, they
introduced the vaccine, the m RNA
vaccine.
And this thing was never tested. It
usually takes about 10 years to develop
a vaccine that's effective. and and
that's when a virus stabilizes. But we
know we know during that time the virus
was constantly mutating. So they
designed a vaccine
to try to stop a constantly mutating
virus which we know doesn't work. Um and
there's a lot of denters like the most
famous I think at that time was Brent uh
Brett Weinstein
and he was telling I I was watching a
lot of his podcasts. Okay. Okay. But he
he was explain explaining to uh his the
public the audience a basic fact about
viruses. Okay. The virus is constantly
shifting mutating. Right. When you have
a vaccine,
the vaccine is
a fortif for fortification against the
virus. But if the virus is shifting,
what the vi virus will do is develop
strategies to evade the fortification. M
right because it can shift your
fortifications cannot. So what you're
doing if you're introducing a vaccine
into this situation is you're training
the virus to to be much more evasive. So
you shouldn't do that. Okay. Very simple
logic, right? We're just using logic
here. I'm just saying, you know, unless
the virus has stabilized, you don't know
what it will do. So don't build
fortifications yet because these fort
for fortifications will be half acid
will not be effective and all that will
happen is the virus become much more um
evasive because of that right simple
fact
how many people took the vaccine
80% of the US well um and was there any
and how many of these people question
the logic and the evidence
behind vaccines
>> 20%.
And after it was revealed that there
might be some side effects to this
vaccines including myocarditis. Okay,
not strong evidence but I'm saying there
might be some side effects because
whenever you introduce a new vaccine
at scale to hundreds of millions of
people, there's always going to be side
effects, right? So myocarditis might be
um one of side effect, but how many
people question that?
Not many. And when you know CNN made fun
of Joe Rogan for promoting Ivor Merin
even though Ivor Mertton was won the
Nobel Prize,
how many people thought CNN was correct?
I mean like like it's just astonishing
how the vast majority of people during
the co era shut off their brains and
just accepted whatever science told them
and just stop asking the most
fundamental basic questions anyone
should ask about anything. Do you think
it's fair to say that
the most popular religion is one that
never feels like a religion? I I would
say so. Yeah.
Science prides itself on being above
religion, on being entirely focused on
the truth. But truth can only be arrived
at through debate, through questioning,
through exploration. How much debate
happened during the COVID epidemic?
None. If you try to debate this, they
shut you down.
They usize you from society.
>> That seems to me like a religion. Yeah,
it's an interesting one. Uh
because if you look at the origins of
it, it's like comes from magic, right?
Yeah. Um
look, I mean,
clearly
that thing was a boweapon of some sort
because in nature viruses do not mutate
that fast. It makes no sense for a virus
to m mutate that fast because a virus is
trying to survive by inserting itself
into a host. So the host dies, it dies
as well, right? So the strategy for a
virus is to be innocuous enough to
infiltrate the host. So why would you
constantly become much more um powerful
over time? Why would you become faster
over time? It makes no it makes no
sense. So clearly this came from game of
function research that I think was um
supported and financed by the US
military.
Um and because Obama had issued um uh a
ban on gay function research, this
research was in subcontract to China,
>> which also tells you the world probably
doesn't work the way you think it does,
right? Because if China and United
States are competitors,
why would the US military subcontract
biological research, biological weapons
research, by the way, to a um research
facility in China that is affiliated
with the Chinese military?
But Professor Jien, you're Chinese. I'm
American. We're supposed we're supposed
to be enemies, right? Yeah. And and and
then the world will be perfect. Yes.
>> What do you think are the three biggest
lies humans have been told?
>> Um
I think the three biggest lies
are
death is the final reckoning whereas I
think death is actually the beginning.
I think that um if if you look at secret
societies the way they initiate you into
the society is through death. They
pretend that you died. They bury you.
And the reason why is that every time
you die, you can look at yourself for
who you are and choose a better path. So
you you're able to let go of who you
are. And that's why I think death is
important because death allows for
rebirth and rejuvenation. It allows for
a reset. Um, and I I I think that's a
mechanism of knowledge accumulation
where if you are making mistake in this
life, don't worry about it because
you're going to die and you you'll
probably come back at a later point and
learn from your from from your mistakes.
But don't be afraid to die. Don't be
afraid of making mistakes. It's all part
of the growing process. So, I think
death is one of the greatest lies and
it's it's a very destructive lie where
for whatever reason, everyone's afraid
to die. So they spend billions of
dollars trying to live forever, right?
So I think that that that's a huge huge
lie.
The second big lie is that we are
individually powerless. We don't matter,
right? So there's this war going on in
Iran. Well, we can't affect its outcome
because we're not warriors. We don't
have an army. So let's just sit back and
watch only fans or play video games or
gamble how the world will will turn out.
But as I say, but but as I said before,
we're all a reflection of the universe
and what we do matters. If we choose to
live a good life ourselves, the universe
will be better for it. So don't worry
about what's happening
um in the Middle East. Don't worry about
geopolitics. Just worry about being a
good person, being kind, open, and
generous to everyone around you. And you
you you have made the world a better
place. Um you do matter and the great
lie is that you don't matter. The great
lie is that you have actually no impact
in this world. And unfortunately, too
many people have believed this lie and
have absolved themselves of both agency
as well as responsibility.
>> I like those a lot. Do you think another
lie is history is random?
So they don't say history is random.
They say history is theological. Meaning
that history is moving towards a greater
purpose and that we improve generation
by generation. Right? So you look at our
advances since the scientific
revolution.
Um and I think that
we've
deluded ourselves into believing that
um we're at the height of civilization
that because we have airplanes that
because we have uh skyscrapers because
we have the internet we've achieved
um the greatest civilization ever in
human history. But then you go and look
you look at a place like Egypt which
built the pyramids
and like we can't explain the pyramids.
We can't even build them today. Yeah. I
mean like so so if we're the greatest
civilization ever in in human history,
why can't we build the pyramids? Um
there's so many there's so much of
history hidden from us. And so um we've
just deluded ourselves into believing
that we're so much better than everyone
else. we're so much superior than every
other civilization that's come before
us. when I don't think that's actually
true. When I think that, you know, if
you go and you explore
um these indigenous communities around
the world, maybe the natives, the Inuit
in Canada or, you know, uh Aboriginal
groups in New Zealand, if you actually
spend time with them, you find that they
are really happy, balanced people with a
deep sense of their own self-worth and
meaning and purpose in their lives. And
I think that's a goal worth striving
for,
>> right? Whereas we're just these empty
vessels
trying to increase the number in our
bank account for no particular reason.
We don't have a story of who we are,
what we're doing here, and where we're
going. They do. And I think that that
that's what gives them joy and purpose
in life. What do you think elites
believe is the secret to living forever?
>> Okay, so
um the elites are actually obsessed with
living forever. Um and there are
different reasons why this is the case.
Uh some have speculated that it's
because they in their hearts know all
the e evil they've done. So they're
afraid of like the reckoning when they
face God.
um they're afraid of like take like
being held accountable for their
actions. So that's one possibility.
Another possibility is they're just
really happy with the life they have
here. So they want to maintain that.
They're afraid of like when they die
they lose everything. Um so I think both
are are possibilities.
But I think that
um the body is not the secret to
eternal life. So you look at someone
like Peter Aia. I'm not sure if you've
seen his work, but he talks about how to
live longer and healthier, right? He
he's very expensive. I mean, um you
know, he'll charge someone I mean
$100,000 a year just to consult on how
to
um live a lifestyle that allows for
maximum uh health uh in in in the long
term. Okay. So people like Peter Tia,
you people like Brian Johnson who is
trying to live uh for as long as he can.
There's a lot of money put into
longevity research, but I think it's all
the wrong approach. I think the secret
is not the body, the secret is the mind,
right? So
I go back to Donald Trump because he's a
very interesting case study for me where
we've never had someone who's been able
to capture global attention for so long.
Right? Before you might be famous in
your community, but that was it.
>> But now with movies, with the internet,
with with digitization,
Donald Trump lives rentree in the minds
of billions of people.
There are people who like literally wake
up every morning and they're like, "Oh,
what what is Donald Trump doing today?"
So they go online and they read the
news. They are fascinated with this guy.
They think about think about him all the
time. And so we've never had a time when
so many people were focused on one
person.
And my question is,
will Donald Trump ever die? Because I
understand, yes, he eats McDonald's
every single day. I understand he is fat
and old, but we never had had a
situation where the entire world is
focused on every second the speech, the
movement of one person. If you just look
at how he spends his day, it's always
with the press, right? It's always
either on true social or giving a press
conference or talking to a reporter.
It's amazing how reporters in Washington
DC are like, "Oh my god, I can call up
the president of the United States and
he'll talk to me for an hour." It's like
literally like any journalist in
Washington DC could do this. You can get
his phone number and he's the president
of the United States and call him up and
he'll tell you, you know, his thinking
and all that. So, it's a very strange
situation and you ask yourself why is he
doing that? Well, I think he's doing
that because he craves the attention
because he wants to live in the
consciousness of the whole world.
We've never had something like that like
that before, right? So, so let's go back
to the um idea that
consciousness is creation of reality.
But what this means is that we create
our own individual reality naturally.
Okay.
But
if
we all have Donald Trump in our minds,
then Donald Trump becomes the
convergence of all individual realities
on planet Earth. And this convergence is
what we call God. So, is it possible
that by constantly thinking about Donald
Trump all the time,
by giving him our psychic attention,
are we basically manifesting God
into Donald Trump so that his
consciousness becomes eternal locked in?
because we make it eternal because we
cannot perceive or imagine or desire a
world without him. There's a certain
addiction to Donald Trump today, right?
Imagine how remember how boring Joe
Biden was, right? We had Donald Trump
and was like, "Oh my god, oh my god,
please go away. I don't want to think
about you anymore." Then we had Joe
Biden like who who no one remembers what
happened during Joe Biden, right?
And now with Donald Trump, which is like
we're back to constantly fretting about
the world, constantly cursing, but
constantly think about him, giving him
all the our attention.
And my question is,
will he die? And I I fear that he won't
die.
I think that's a secret to longevity
where you are able to implant yourself
in the consciousnesses of so many people
that their consciousness creates a
reality in which you can inhabit
forever.
It's really fascinating if you look at
the history of memes. uh I think it was
Richard Dawkins
that had proposed like mimemetics in the
first place and Trump is the greatest
meme of all time and you know this
because what was the biggest meme coin
Trumpcoin uh so it signals I don't know
it's what really gives a god power when
you think about it do you think the
answer is just attention your active
consciousness
>> yes
he he's a psychic demon okay And you
feed a psych psychot demon fu intense
emotions and there's so many intense
emotions surrounding Donald Trump.
People either hate him or love him. He
doesn't care because it's all emotions
that that empowers him, right? For him,
hate love is the same thing. H
So, so again, this is a thought
experiment, but the question is, is he
going to die? Because he's not going to
go away. Okay? As long as he can stay in
that office, he's not going to die.
And like quite honestly, there's no way
to get get rid of him now.
>> Do you think the elite believe they're
from sacred bloodlines?
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> Is it all the one bloodline or is it
like multiple bloodlines?
>> Yeah, they say 13 bloodlines. So I mean
I I think it's this game theory where
you're born into power and privilege and
you go to place like Endover, Yale,
Harvard Law School, and you meet people
who are smarter than you are. So how can
you explain to yourself why you're more
powerful than these people? And the
answer is my blood is better. My blood
is pure. I have dragon blood. I have
divine blood from Hercules, from
Achilles, from Max the Great. That's why
I should rule the world because I'm not
gonna give up my position. I'm not gonna
admit that this other guy is better than
I am.
>> I should rule. And the best explanation
for why I should rule is because I've
always ruled because I I'm a
reincarnation of a divine being on on
Earth,
right? And that's something that Jeffrey
Epstein believed.
That's a fascinating one. I'm sure you
could look at the history of like these
ancestry.coms and 23 andmemes and I'm
sure it's strange, but uh cuz how else
would you determine the bloodline
without the DNA test? Uh and you
shouldn't actually participate in in any
of those things.
>> Why?
>> Because um a conspiracy theory, okay, I
I'll just throw this out there, okay?
But a conspiracy theory is that um
they want certain bloodlines and they
use these websites to find certain
bloodlines. So if you're in that
bloodline,
bad things could happen to you.
Why is there so much human trafficking
in the United States?
They care a lot about blood blood lines,
right? So if they believe that they are
divine of divine bloodline, they would
also want to prevent others from of
divine bloodline from accessing power,
right? They want to they would want to
step out other bloodlines. They could
also drink the blood of other bloodlines
to increase their own bloodline.
>> You know, again, this is conspiracy
theory. I have no evidence this is the
case. But if you if you you if you were
to actually examine how these people
think, you know, and these people are
like insane.
This makes sense. So, what bloodline
would you have to be for them to
would you have to be of that 13 families
or would you be of just not that? Um, so
I think that it depends on the group
that you're in. I think there's
something called the 13 bloodlines,
>> which traces um themselves back to the
Roman Empire basically. Um, but then you
have the Sabine Frankus.
>> Mhm.
>> Who are maybe about few hundred families
um and Jeffy Epstein was of the
bloodline of the Sapine Frankus.
>> So there's overlap, but there's also
some distinctions. So, you know,
honestly, I have not done that that much
research into these bloodlines because I
think um it's not really helpful. I'm
more interested in ideas. Um because
these people are not smart and their
behavior is sort of pre-ordained. You'll
know exactly how how they will behave.
Um I'm much more interested in people
like Donald Trump who
regardless of what you think about him,
he actually has an imagination. He
actually
>> has a connection to the divine perhaps.
>> He thinks he does. Yeah. And he probably
does.
>> Yeah. Something I found fascinating from
our conversation yesterday when we'd had
a chat was that your belief that you
have a belief that there isn't like uh
one most powerful person in the world.
>> Yeah.
>> And that logics out to me. Uh and it
also logics out to me that we'd be
allowed to say it because uh the person
who thinks they're the most powerful in
the world would want us to say their
name.
>> Exactly. Exactly. That's exactly right.
>> And the person uh
>> Yeah. I I don't think anyone wouldn't
want us to say their name. That makes
sense.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so, so I mean they say like these
these secret societies are promoted by
secret societies, right? So go going
back to the example of the Illuminati.
Okay. Illuminati was founded at the end
of the 18th century by Adam Weisshop who
was forming a Jesuit and the Jesuits are
crypto Jews and he aligned with Jacob
Frank and Mayor Rothschild and they
formed the Illuminati.
And when you ever form whenever you form
a secret society, okay, your major
problem is actually recruitment. How do
you get people to join your um
organization? And Adam Weisshop um was
able to grow the Illuminati because he
was he was a master media media
manipulator. Okay. So he created the
myth that there are these people who are
seeking to conquer the world and they're
infiltrated throughout Europe in all the
major noble lineages and they've
infiltrated the Freemasons as well and
they're conspiring to overthrow
um these dynasties of Europe, right? And
so he was the one who was promoting this
myth because if you're just this average
Joe and you read about these guys,
they're like, "This is actually pretty
cool. Yeah, I should join these guys."
And it gives it gives it much more
political leverage, right? So So, so
that that's what people don't really
appreciate about the illuminati. It's
actually more of a PR um campaign than
that than is actually a powerful force
in the world. But but again remember
this goes back to Donald Trump and
Plato's cave. Consciousness is reality
itself. If you can make enough people
believe this to be true, it becomes
true. You've talked about various secret
societies. You've talked about various
scops uh made different predictions
about the system. Is there anything that
you, Professor Jeang, are allowed to
say?
I think that if you refer to certain
individuals
and their actions,
they would come after you because as
long as you talk in the abstract like,
okay, this is how secret societies rule
the world, that's fine. They don't care.
No one cares. You talk about how
Jeffrey Epstein is connected to this
person and it's this person that
financed certain parts of his behavior.
um this would create problems for him
and then it would come create problems
for you. So I think um naming names
going into specifics is a problem.
Another problem is let's just say I had
access to confidential information that
someone shared with me
>> and I were to if I were to reveal that
to you well that would be a problem
because then I would have betrayed that
person,
>> right?
>> Um and I don't do that because like I
don't know any powerful people and no
one's ever told me any secrets, right?
So a lot of things I do is based on
speculation, based on analysis and no
one cares if you do that. But again, if
you name someone powerful and you reveal
certain of his behavior that can be um
that can be used as legal evidence
against him, that can cause for
incrimination against him. Uh that would
be a problem. If you had information
revealed to you by a confidential source
and you were to reveal this confidential
information to other people and make it
public, um that that would set you up
for retribution as well. So I would say
these two things. Most of your critics
say that what you're doing is
technically illegal in your home country
and the only reason you haven't gotten
trouble is because you're a CCP asset or
a CIA asset or an MI6 asset.
Professor Jeang, are you a spy? Okay,
sure. So, let me respond to the
question. How am I allowed to do what I
do in China? And the reason is that I'm
actually not part of the Chinese system.
>> So the Chinese system is set up to
control the behavior
of Chinese citizens.
Um, and so it's a very complicated
bureaucracy. I'm not a Chinese citizen.
I'm not a participant in the Chinese
system. I'm a foreigner hired to teach
English at a private school. That's my
identity. That's my role in China. And
foreigners are given a lot of leeway in
China. Like we operate in a gray zone
where we don't really matter and we're
sort of like tolerated, but we don't
really matter. Okay. And so an example
of this is um if you're if you have a
Chinese ID, then you're part of the
Chinese AI surveillance grid, meaning
that everything that you say is
monitored. Everything that you do is
monitored. um when you use any Chinese
payment system that information is
always stored online and the database is
constructed to profile you. Okay? But
it's a system designed for Chinese
citizens. And why you do that is you're
not interested in individual behavior.
You're interested in collective
behavior. So you're trying to figure out
this person's social network and then
you can profile this social network and
then use mechanisms to manipulate that
um social network. Hey, does that does
that make sense to you? Okay. In other
words, I don't matter. I'm not part of
the system. Whatever I do does not
impact how the system is is run and
managed. Okay. The system is meant is
meant to control the people inter
internal to China, not external to it.
China has absolutely no desire to
conquer the world because it' be a pain
in the ass. Right. So, um that's a lot.
That's why I'm allowed to do what I do
as long as I'm not on social media in
China. As long as I do I do not do
public speeches in China, as long as I
don't talk to Chinese reporters, I don't
matter in the system. Okay. But the
moment, okay, and and this is a caveat.
The moment I I decide, you know what? I
I I want to be famous in China, I want
to set up set up a social media account,
I want to give speeches and generate
income, now I'm a problem, right? So I I
make that that distinction where I
choose freedom
but I also choose not to um engage in
lucrative opportunities in China.
>> But if I were to engage in in lucrative
opportunities then then I would be
expected to say certain things that
promote the party line in the world and
in China. Hm. Like if you saw an
American influencer perhaps speaking
Chinese to a classroom of American
students and they were talking about the
topics you're talking about, but like
for China, like what would you think
that is going on? Random question really
quick. Have you ever looked up if the
shampoo you're using can disrupt your
hormones? Cuz if you're like me, you
probably didn't know that over 70% of
men's grooming products have chemicals
that can disrupt your endocrine system
or your testosterone levels. Now, I care
a lot about my health, but I didn't
really think any healthy products could
make my hair look good. So, that's why I
was so glad I met the guys at Based.
They gave me their shower duo shampoo
conditioner, and it's made with
plant-based ingredients like peppermint
or argan oil. So, there's no sulfates,
no hormone disruptors, nothing that's
going to mess with your body. And after
using it for a while now, genuinely my
hair does feel way healthier, like clean
and hydrated as opposed to dry and dull.
And honestly, I think it looks better,
too. So, if you've been using the same
products forever without thinking twice
about what's actually in them, make sure
to check out Bass Body Works. It's a
plant-based, all-natural men's grooming
brand that actually performs. So, if you
guys want to try it out, just go to
jackneil.com/based
and use the code jackneal at checkout
for 20% off your first order. Plus, you
get a free toiletry bag when you buy
your first set. So, again, that is
jackneil.com/based
or you can scan the QR code on screen.
But anyway, guys, back to the podcast.
Like if you saw an American influencer
perhaps speaking Chinese to a classroom
of American students and they were
talking about the topics you're talking
about but like for China like what would
you think that is going on? I would have
actually no idea what's going on. I'd be
like first of all who is this guy and
where is he getting his information?
Second of all I'd be like why is he
allowed to teach his stuff to students?
I mean like there doesn't have a
supervisor. Isn't there like a high
school principal that oversees a
curriculum? And then third of all, it's
like what motivates this guy? Why why is
he doing what what he's doing? Cuz like
this is not going to help kids get into
college. It's not going to help them uh
do well in the SAT. This is all just
silly. I would have absolutely no idea
what's going on. I'd be completely
confused. I'd be flabber flabbergasted
by by this guy. I I would absolutely no
idea who he is. I would not know why
he's doing what he's doing. and I'd be
confused as to how he's able to get away
with this crap. And do you feel like
your answers so far have answered that
pretty fully?
>> Um,
if you just go in my history, I do all
sorts of strange things.
Um, people who know me aren't surprised
by what I do. They're surprised by how
famous I become,
but they're not surprised by what I do.
I'm I'm I'm just a strange guy, right?
because I went to Yale and I come to
China
and I spend my entire life here just
teaching and I'm like impoverished
as compared to my Yale classmates,
right, who've become lawyers and doctors
and who live very respectful lives on
the Upper West Side in New York. Um, so
when I first got into Yale,
all my cousins hated me because now
they're under pressure to get into Ivy
League as well. Then like 10 years
later,
um, I hear a story of how my cousin got
into a fight with his mother and his
mother said to him, "You have to work
harder because you you want to be like
Uncle Jang and get into into Yale." And
then the cousin was like, "Yeah, mom,
but he went back to China." And that
ended the conversation. I was never
mentioned again in that household. So,
so, so I mean my my my entire my
relatives, my family is shocked by how
strange I am. Like you go to Yale, like
you win, you win the lottery and you
decide, you know what? I'm going to just
foot away and go to a place where my my
other degree doesn't really matter where
I I can't become a doctor or lawyer. I
can only be a become a high school
teacher. So I'm just a strange person in
general. And then you know like you know
um in 2008 I built China's first public
school international program
to send Chinese kids to America for
college. And at that time, this was a
new field and everyone knew it was like
a rocket ship. I could become a
millionaire just helping Chinese kids
apply to university. A lot of people did
become millionaires. But after a couple
years of doing that, I walked away
because I didn't want to do this for the
rest of my life. I didn't want to become
a business person. I didn't want to make
millions of dollars getting rich kids
into Yale and Harvard. I walked away.
I worked for United Nations in 2006. And
look, when you work for United Nations,
it is the cushiest,
easiest
life anyone can live. Okay? It is the
silliest thing ever to exist. But like I
literally was making six figures
doing nothing every day, just sitting in
my office and pretending to type on uh a
keyboard. And I and like if I had a
family, every one of my kids would be
given free international schooling. If I
flew around, it'd be business class. I'd
be given a pension after 10, 20 years, a
full pension.
I was treated like royalty wherever I
wherever I went because I'm the United
Nations.
Um, and I walked away because like
because I did I thought it was a
meaningless existence.
So,
I'm often confused by
myself. Um, people think, you know, my
friends tell me, you know, they don't
they don't understand why I do what I
do. Um, so,
uh, it's led me to this point.
And again, like people, my friends are
not surprised by what I do what I do,
which is, you know, teach conspiracy
theories in high school. Like that's
just part of my personality. But they're
kind of surprised by I have like two
million followers right now on YouTube,
right? They're kind of surprised by
that. It's like and and like these are
Yale Harvard people, right? So they
they're very conservative. there. They
have a very rigid worldview and they
don't understand how I'm able to
teach this and be so popular um in the
world. Did you manifest this?
That's a really good question. Um
the short answer is yes.
But the real answer is I imagine this
possibility, right? I um but you know
the the thing though is that I am a
writer by training like I write books
and so I imagine things all the time and
I imagine that this could be a
possibility one day
>> and I position myself I maneuver myself
into
um this position. So 5 years ago during
COVID, I was so upset about CO. It
really annoyed me how the entire world
just shut off its brain, right? Just
like, okay, well, you know, this
vaccine, well, we don't know if it
works, but some scientist said it works,
so it must work, so I'll just put it in
my body, hope for the best. I was it was
just insane to me. I I've been
fascinated um by social media, uh by the
internet. So I was watching a lot of Joe
Rogan. I was watching a lot of Jimmy
Door. I was watching a lot of
alternative media and I I became drawn
to alternative media because like I like
debate. I like conversation. I like
exploration. It seemed to me like people
like Jimmy Door, Joe Rogan, uh Brett and
Eric Weinstein,
um Tucker Carlson,
these were people that was that that
were trying to seek the truth, that were
really questioning the world. And I was
like, you know, I would one day like to
be on their show,
you know, I I feel that's the direction
I could go. And so then I asked myself,
okay, if I want to be like them, because
only by being like them can I appear on
their show, right? They're not going to
like ask a random high school teacher to
be on their show. What can I do that
makes me so distinct
that
I might be popular on social media?
And my solution was, I'm going to make
some stupid predictions and hope they
turn out correct. And if they aren't
correct, I'm going to be a laughing
stock for the rest of my life. But if
they are correct, then I might uh get on
Taco Carlson,
right? So that was my strategy and
planning when I start the YouTube
channel.
It sounds so silly, right? Are are are
you telling me that you didn't believe
those predictions? So I believe my
predictions. I believe it would turn out
the way
um they did very strongly because
remember I had to first of all explain
my predictions and justify my
predictions but I also tip myself and
put on YouTube right which means that
now there's a historical record that I
made these predictions and I would only
do that if I truly believed in them but
what happened was that um for the past
five six errors.
I was having conversation with friends
and we'd have these silly arguments
about geopolitics. Like
I would we argued about who the
Democratic nominee would be in 2020 and
and I was like why are we having this
stupid argument? It's going to be Joe
Biden. Okay. And like they there was a
lot of push button says no no it's going
to be Pete Buddhajette. It's going to be
Kamala Harris because we want a younger
candidate. And I'm like it doesn't
matter what you want. It's m it matters
how the world works and Joe Biden's
going to be the nominee. Um I also
predicted that Trump would win in 2020
and beat Joe Biden. Um and then the you
and then there was talk of Putin
invading Ukraine, attacking Ukraine, and
my friends were like, "It's not going to
happen. There's no way. It's too
dangerous." And Putin would lose. I'm
like, "Oh my god, this is so silly. This
is all obviously going to happen." And
for whatever reason, all my friends
believe the complete opposite. And I
can't talk to my friends anymore. It's
just pointless. These are Yale Harvard
people who are supposed to be like the
some of the smartest people in the
world. And they have like these thick
skulls and like it's almost impossible
to relay obvious reality to them. So
screw this. I'm I'm I'm going to make my
own YouTube channel and uh just speak my
heart basically.
Do you think the reason you're able to
nail some of these predictions is
because you went into Yale as a poor kid
and just saw how these rich like elite
that type of consciousness that group
identity like how they behave and how
they win games and like you're just able
to see it for what it is and they're so
stuck inside of it that they can't see
it. They're too biased.
>> Okay. So, um, the thing about Yale is
when you're a poor kid and you get in a
place at Yale, which is like I mean the
height of elite power, okay? Um, you're
traumatized by the event.
All my time at Yale, I felt like an
imposttor. Like I don't really belong
here
and you're traumatized by the alienation
because you don't belong here because
you're not because you're not rich and
they don't they don't they don't want
actually want to talk to you. Um, and so
Yale was an alienating and traumatic
experience for me. And when that
happens, you go you you you
disassociate, right? So I wasn't
actually observing how power works
because because I was never invited to
their parties anyway and I was not
friends with them. So I never I didn't
understand how power power works. Um,
and so I developed a very naive
understanding of the world, which was
that the world was a meritocracy, which
is like the best ideas will always win
out. So it didn't matter if I didn't
have any friends. It didn't matter if if
I didn't have any money, it didn't
matter if I didn't have any connections.
All mattered was if I just did the best
job possible, whatever I did, I'd be
successful. And that was my
understanding leaving Yale. And so I go
out into the world and I try many
different things. I tried being a
journalist. I tried being a documentary
filmmaker.
And no matter what I did, it was failure
after failure. And I didn't I didn't
think that the people who are my
colleagues in these industries were
necessarily better than I was.
And I was sort of surprised by this. And
I became very angry at myself for not
succeeding because I thought the entire
point of going to Yale was to be
successful and I was not succeeding. So
um I became very anxious. I became very
depressed. And for many years I sunk
into a deep depression.
And no matter what I did, I couldn't
escape my uh depression. And then in
2008, I got a job
building and managing China's first
public school study abro.
But the process of building the program
um left me traumatized because I spent
my entire heart and soul into building
the program to validate myself and I
couldn't control myself emotionally and
I got into a fight with my boss and so
he fired me or I quit whatever you know
um but
um after that I was like clearly there's
something wrong with me clearly I need
to think about who I am how I got to
this point and how I can how I can
improve myself. So, I wrote an article
at that time called
three things Yale didn't teach me and I
listed three fundamental problems with
my education, my own psychology. And the
first problem is I thought that IQ
was the end all beall. So if you're able
to articulate yourself clearly, if
you're able to do math, well, you should
be president of the United States.
Whereas if you are not able to
articulate clearly, then you should be a
janitor. Okay? So I saw the world
through the lens of IQ. I didn't
appreciate that the world was much more
diverse than I than I uh um believed.
That's the first issue. Second issue is
I believe the world was a zero- sum
competition. So, I'm on YouTube and so I
need to have the most YouTube views,
have the most YouTube um subscribers,
otherwise I'm nothing.
And so, I saw everyone as a competitor.
I couldn't take pleasure in the pleasure
of others. I when others were happy, I
became very unhappy because like why
were they happier than I was? Okay. So,
I saw the I saw the world um through
that lens. And the third problem is
I saw failure not as an opportunity to
grow and to learn but as a testament to
my own deficiencies. So I was afraid to
fail. I didn't want to lose. Um it was
the most traumatic experience to fail
and to to lose. And so I recognized that
these three things were setting me back
and I needed to reinvent myself. I need
to die basically. I needed to um keep
myself. And so what I did was this. I
redesigned my education,
right? Y at Yale, you just went to
school with the best and the brightest.
You were taught by professors who were
eloquent, who were um very scholarly.
And so I said, I'm going to throw myself
into a world. I'm gonna interact with
ordinary people and do ordinary things.
Right? So I signed up for cooking school
and the first day I go to cooking
school. I imagine I manifi I manifested
myself that oh in a year's time I will
be the world's greatest chef because my
classmates don't know Shakespeare.
They never went to Yale whereas I did.
So I'm superior to them. Okay. So, at
the end of this year, my ambition is I'm
I'm I'm going to have my own restaurant
empire. I'm going to have like a
thousand restaurants all around the
world. I'm going to have my own TV show
and I'll be the best cook in the world.
Okay? And of course, I was a complete
disaster
in the kitchen. I didn't know anything.
And I was like the worst student in the
class. And these are like vocational
kids, by the way. They were like 18, 19.
They were working as like short order
cooks in a airport bar. They were coming
at night to take this class because they
loved cooking. There was a passion. And
um so at the end of each class when you
cook three meal, three dishes, you
present it to the chef
and then the chef would give it a grade.
And I was so bad that the chef would not
even touch my dishes. He like, "I'm not
eating this crap. Go away, man."
I was like, "What is it wrong you
people? Don't you people know I went to
Yale?" Like, "What is it wrong, you
idiots?" Um, but that was this disaster
as a um cooking student. It and it was
complete humiliation, but it taught me
that the world isn't the way you think
it is. So, I need to reexamine my own
values.
I also took Brazilian jiu-jitsu classes
and
um Brazilian jiu-jitsu is a weird sport
because you you don't know anything and
what they do is they beat you up for a
year and you go and like oh hey uh we're
going to roll and you're like okay so
are we going to train? No, no, someone's
going to come and beat you up for a
year. And that's what happened. And like
every day after class, I just go home
and cry because I remembered when I was
a um student in Toronto, like in primary
school and in junior high school, and
every day I get beat I get beat up by
bullies and I go home and cry. And was
the same was happening to me again
taking Brazilian jiu-jitsu. The
difference of course is like now I'm
paying good money to get beaten up and
bullied uh and cry. Um, I did stand up
comedy and stand up comedy was a
revelation because
um, all my entire life I was afraid of
being laughed at. Like I had I had to
like prove myself and when I got up on
the stage and I told jokes and people
actually thought I was funny. Um, I
recognized that when they laugh that
made me feel good about myself.
It made me feel good to be vulnerable,
to expose myself, to humiliate myself in
front of others, bring them happiness,
brought me happiness. And so that so
that was a revelation. Um and so I I
also learned not to take take myself too
seriously like like the healthiest
healthiest thing is just to be able to
laugh at yourself. Um I did rock
climbing. Um and rock climbing was also
really important because
rock climbing it's a social thing. Is
that is that a competition? And at first
when
people in the gym were able to do much
harder climbs than I was, I was kind of
like angry and jealous.
But, you know, when whenever I tried a
hard climb and people around me were
cheering me on, I recognized that, wow,
if they can cheer me on, why can't I
cheer them on? If they were able to find
happiness in my success, why can't I
find happiness in their success? Um, I
did skydiving
for a few months.
Don't do that. Like, this the dumbest
thing you can do. Okay. Those guys were
in drugs, right? Um, yeah, it was just
dumb. And like, but but I was trying
different things. So, skydiving was
Yeah, just don't don't try that. They're
all drug on drugs. They're all
Um,
and yeah, I tried everything. I I tried
singing
um because I was tonedeaf and I spent
like $10,000 so that I can sing some
notes like oh
something like that. I can't sing. Okay.
But like it just it was just a lot of
money. And every day my teacher was just
shouting at me and saying you're an
idiot. You can't you know sing. like and
um and that was also um a humility
experience that taught me to be much
more um to have much more empathy in in
life. And so that experience was very
transformative because I recognized that
education is not about going to the best
schools
and getting the best grades. It was
really about
taking risk, trying new things.
and engaging in a process of
self-reflection
and um it was really about humility,
empathy, resilience and that taught me
to be a better teacher as well as a
better person. Um, and you know, the
great thing about that experience is
that it didn't really save me from my
anxiety, from my depression, but it
opened my heart to the possibility of
being saved. And that I felt that I'm
now worthy of being saved. I'm now
worthy of sharing my life with another
person. Whereas before I was afraid
and so I was able to let go my ego and
fear. And I and so I I even today I tell
people like the two your two greatest
enemies are ego and fear.
Your belief that you're alone in the
universe and your belief that you will
fail. Um so having let go of my ego and
fear now have I've opened up my heart I
was able to find the love of my life.
Something I'd asked you last night was
what was the moment that you noticed
everything was an illusion? like what
was the moment that you could see past
the veil and see that all this was fake?
>> Yeah. So, um I met my wife 10 years ago
and
um at first I didn't want to start a
relationship because I had had I hit
rock bottom. I had no money because I
spent it all on skydiving.
I was unemployed.
Um I didn't have a house. I was actually
working for rent.
And um just by accident I met my wife.
>> Where'd you meet her?
>> Um I was um helping out a college
program and she was also part of the
team and she saw something in me and so
she wanted to date me. So she took she
took the initiative and I was kind of
indifferent. Um, but we we went out a
few times and
we just connected, you know, we we we
just clicked and we we were able to be
intimate with with each other. And so,
one thing led to another and then we
were married. We had our first child.
Now, we have three kids. And for this
time, I was afraid that this was just an
illusion, that this was not real, that
she'll eventually wake up and said, "Oh
my god, why am I dating an unemployed
um middle-aged man who's who might be
gay?" Um why am I doing that? Um but but
she never left me and we've been
together ever since. And and it feels as
though we were just meant to be to be
together. It meant it was meant I feel
as though we we're like soulmates like
we are two sparks drifting in the
universe and we wanted to find each
other and so we were able to somehow
navigate the messiness of this world,
navigate chaos and somehow find each
other because we were looking for each
other all this time. Like that's
literally how I feel about her. Um, and
you know, she saved my life. She
transformed my life. And she was able to
bring structure and purpose and meaning
to my life when none existed before.
Before I was like, I just want to
succeed. I don't know why I I want to
succeed, but I want to succeed. Now it's
like, I don't need to succeed. Now I
just need to take care of my family. Now
I just need to be a good role model to
my kids. Now I Now I just need to spend
as much time as possible with my family
and enjoy my time here with with my
family. And um
just having that spirit,
just by letting go, just by seeing the
world as an illusion, seeing that
success means nothing. It's family that
matters.
Strangely enough,
um I became much more creative. Um I
wrote a book that was published in
China. I wrote a series of science
fiction uh novels. It was it was just a
time of tremendous creative output and I
started to teach and when I teach I was
not interested in just teaching English.
I wanted to be a role model to my kids.
I wanted to be like be able to teach my
kids and so I started to teach a great
books Homer Dante Plato Kant. Um, and I
had very, very little exposure to a lot
of these books. And so I set myself on
learning them as much as possible. And
at first it was kind of okay because you
can always watch YouTube videos and just
imitate them, these professors who teach
Plato and Homer. But then I got into
Dante.
And for six months, I was watching these
YouTube videos about Dante Nan comedy. I
had no idea what they were saying. I was
so confused. I was reading Divine Comedy
like every single day because I really
wanted to master it and I had no idea
what I was reading. I was just so lost.
I was so frustrated.
And so I went to sleep one one day and I
woke up and I felt as though Dante had
spoken to me and he he and I and his
word was love. focus on love. That's
what divine comedy is about, love. And
so I started to reread it again and then
things started to unpack themselves,
slowly reveal themselves before me. And
um it wasn't at once, but it was like as
though before I just saw gray and now
I'm able to see color slowly, piece by
piece. And um and and then I recognized
something which is the universe is
divine. The universe is alive. The
universe is conscious. And if you have
the faith, if you have the love in your
heart, it will speak back to you. It
will guide you. It will lead you to the
um to to the light. But first, you have
to open yourself to love. Love is the
great secret of the universe.
>> Right.
Professor Jang, you've spent your life
studying how powerful people enslave the
weak. You know how war, religion, and
debt are used to create fear and give
them control. If all your lectures were
deleted, every book, every article
erased from history,
what's the one truth about humans you
would leave to the world?
Um,
look, if tomorrow, for whatever reason,
all my lectures were deleted, it
wouldn't change anything. It wouldn't
matter because I feel as though I've
ignited a spark in a lot of people. It's
a spark that compels them to seek the
truth for themselves. So, these videos
are not to be are not meant to be the
truth. They're not meant to be the
Bible. They're not meant to be
scripture. This is meant to be a
uh way
to inspire you to seek your own truth.
And I think there's a global awakening
happening. I think I've started a
movement of sorts. I I I mean I mean I
come to Hong Kong and it's amazing how a
lot of people recognize me and they come
up to me and and tell me how much they
love my lectures.
And
I was at breakfast this morning, my
hotel,
and one of the hotel staff, this young
Filipino lady. And I would expect this
is like the last person to watch my
videos, right? As I was getting to
leave,
um, she said to me, "Goodbye, Professor
Dia." So she recognized me and like this
is a you know Filipino lady working as a
waitress in a hotel in Hong Kong. So
it's amazing
the impact I've had already.
And I think that once you ignite that
spark in people,
it changes just the entire way they see
the world. And you can never you you can
never go back.
I guess what's the best piece of advice
you've ever received?
Don't chase
So, I'll tell you the story where I was
a young um teacher
aspiring journalist in Beijing. This is
this is about the year 1999 and I had
just graduated from Yale. This is the
autumn.
And um a journalist friend calls me and
says, "So there's this famous American
writer, Gay Tiss. You probably haven't
heard of him. He's like 94 this year."
Okay. He's a very famous writer. Uh
probably like the last
um great living American writer.
>> He he he was off the um Kurt Vonagget,
um Tom Wolf, David Hammerstein
generation, and they're all dead. He's
still alive. and I was his assistant for
six months because he needed a
translator.
And so I follow him everywhere and I was
translating for him and
he saw me as a son. He saw me um as a
prodig
all these decades. We email we we email
each other now and then.
And the best advice he gave me which
still sticks in my mind is don't chase
Um because
first of all he's a very attractive man
who's
you know um had many many uh
relationships
in the past. So the turning point in his
life is he's married to a woman named
Nanteliss and she is a very famous
editor at random house and in 1970s
they were walking
um in time square after dinner goes out
every single night and he hangs out with
like the most famous people in New York
like people like Truman Capot um George
Plimpmpton they're all they're all like
very good friends and um he got
interested in the massage parlor which
was basically a brothel
and he went in and and this started his
book called Thy Thy Neighbor's wife
which is which is looking at promiscuity
in
um America and to do to research the
book he participated in sex orgies in
California. He became a brothel manager
in New York. Uh he participated in sex
cults. So So um he did all that. The
problem is that his wife, Nently, would
find out about this because every Sunday
she'd read the New York Times and
there's an article about him having an
origy in California
and that sort of um u ruined their
marriage as you can imagine. They're
still married actually. It's really
interesting how they're still married
after all that. And this was the 1970s
by the way. Um so that's just the power
of love. But I would not want to do what
he did. I would not want to participate
in a sex cult or start a sex cult by the
way. Um and then have my wife find about
about it online because some some guy
some YouTuber made a video about it. Um
you know, so um yeah, don't chase
And then I guess I'll just add this at
the end. If you wanted
if you could recommend one book to
everyone, what would it be?
>> Well, I mean, Divine Comedy is the
greatest book ever written,
um, it is literally,
um,
a word from God. So Dante was channeling
the universe when he wrote that. So
that's the one
book that everyone must read. Um,
but it's really hard. I I I spent a lot
of time researching it and I'm still
trying to decipher its full meaning
because it's so intense. It's truth
itself embedded in in in the in the
poetry.
But if people are just looking to read a
really good book, then um it has to be
Homers the Iliad.
>> I've taught that many times. And it's
amazing how these high school students
in China who have abely no exposure to
Western culture and who themselves don't
actually speak that good English, they
just love the Iliad. Even today, many
years later, they still rave about the
Iliad and it just stays with you. It's
easy. It's an easy read. It's a long
read, but it's an easy read. It's a fun
read as well. And it just forever
transforms you. So, the Iliad.
Beautiful. Uh,
well, everyone, this has been your
guest, Professor Jeang. This is the Jack
Neil podcast.
Where can people find you?
>> Um, I happen to be everywhere now, so
it's pretty easy to find me, but the
best place is u my YouTube channel,
Predict Predictive History.
>> Right. Yeah. Yeah.
>> You also have a substack as well,
>> right? So, if you're interested in
geopolitics, because I write about
current events and try to put it um in a
larger structural lens, uh my Substack
is predictivehistory.substack.com.
Perfect. Awesome. Well, I appreciate you
coming on. Thanks for having me, Jack.